bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj oggi
siamo su su motori dreams avevo detto
che avrei continuato questa serie
avevo fatto questo esperimento un paio
di settimane fa avevo messo il primo
video di sui motori dreams e avevo detto
che se fosse piaciuto l'episodio avrei
fatto una serie di sicuro
l'episodio veramente ha fatto un
successo assurdo e allora ragazzi ci
metto tanto ad evitare su motori perché
ogni volta che cambia la mappa devo
stoppare attaccare un'altra clip quindi
con l'editing è un casino ma per voi lo
faccio lo faccio anche volentieri
ok raga questa si chiama
mai però le mine sul ponte però non ha
idea di che cosa possa essere nel senso
che non pensa esploda al ponte anche
perché non ci sono le esplosioni su
motori credo ok sono caduto subito
vabbè secondo già un traguardo
e vabbè voglio provare a passare un
attimo se esplode ma non esplode ci sono
le mine ma non esplode quindi e non ha
senso che si chiami così ti aiuto io
vieni bianco vieni no no è accaduto che
idiota arrivo light ti faccio compagnia
almeno beh oddio oggi sono partito in
orbita che è successo no no no no no
queste spettacolare ragazzi è stato
spettacolare dori farlo assolutamente
assolutamente devo rifarlo assolutamente
ok vado ok ok no no no no no no bene va
bene almeno non cade però io non cado
prima io non cado stronzo no cari prima
tu cadi prima no madonna
ok ragazzi amo su meteors shower ok c'è
un bel tappeto non è fantastico io vado
direttamente dagli altri non è odio
oddio che cazzo ne il marrone è morto è
saltato tipo falsa cosa è successo sono
l'ultimo sono no no no
raga non ha senso stagionale ha proprio
senso guarda guarda il marrone vada ok
io io sto a guardare perché fantastico
guardate il marrone fissatelo bene
finché vivo ok non c'è più
non c'è vivo bene è stato è stato un
bravo ragazzo per quanto è durato io
sono sparito non mi vedo più
ok è crollato tutto bene ok ragazzi amo
su main field non ideali e cosa sia ma è
bella grossa
vabbè io economy uomo perché ci ho paura
ok ok non so se ciò ok primo privato o
no che se successo mi ha beccato una
tegola perfetto
[Musica]
ok ragazzi riprova stavolta ci vado
dritto anche in mezzo vai così
verde verde tu che mi stai sicuro che se
almeno sei caduto prima di me questo già
è tanto cosa fa il marrone questa
notifica addio siamo morti
perfetti ok vai così bungee jumping
perfetto è la volta buona che qualcuno
si piglia una tegola in testa raga non
assenza non ha senso perfetto si stanno
stuprando a vicenda arrivo anch'io
arrivo arrivo cambio livello perché non
ho più niente da commentare su questo
cosa fa cosa sta facendo il blues
cosa fai agli attacchi spastici vabbè
cambio ma non ha senso ragazzo livello e
si chiama oh my god
soltanto amg non ho idea di che cosa
possa mai così in due è data da perth a
me non ha senso ragazzi sto gioco non sa
o non sarà cosa è svenuto e svenuto e
svenuto
ok catapultarsi sui motori dreams
provoca svenimento è normale perfetto
sono l'unico rimasto sul tatami ho vinto
e poi sono svenuto di nuovo perfetto
cambia livello prima che da di stomaco
tables non idea di che cosa possa essere
tables ok perfetto siamo effettivamente
su dei tavoli come li raggiungo gli
altri mi basta sta fermo number one in
cima al mondo la cosa su cos'è oddio
culo all'aria proprio non mi vedo più
perfetto sta allagando ma non importa è
un'orgia di livelli improponibili questa
ok perfetto perché non posso alzare io
mi sta uscendo dallo schermo il mio
personaggio raga mista svenendo davanti
perfetto ok va bene
incontro livello incontrollabile
crollano i tavoli ok sono il disastro va
bene questo era un livello senza senso
devo riuscire a trovarne un altro prima
che implode al computer che sta
allagando scusatemi se sto cambiando
parecchi i livelli ragano veramente ma
non avete idea di quanti ce ne sono
proviamo questo corsa a ostacoli a sono
solo io sono solo io
beh ragazzi il primo livello in solo
cosa cosa devo fare nomi regole anche in
piedi cosa vuoi che faccia la corsa a
ostacoli
io io vado avanti anche perché sta
crollando pavimento piano piano piano ok
ok siamo riusciti arrivare alla fine
senza cadere
devo sceglierne una ragazza glie the
voice sinistra centro o destra centro va
bene
spero che tutti abbiate letto centro
perché sono fatto un file vai per
capitano mi sono spaventato
ok
no anche sull'altra no anche sull'altra
notte alzati prima che esploda raga non
riesco ad alzarmi ma tra pochi esplode
pure questa alzati alzati prima che
esploda alzati
no no pure sul e vabbè tanto oramai
manca soltanto l'ultima perfetto ok ma
c'è un altro posto sono arrivato al
piano di sopra
ok c'era un'altra strada non l'avevo
vista ho dovuto farmi esplodere tre
volte per riuscire ad arrivare a sto
punto però proseguiamo qua vedo delle
piattaforme delimitate quindi ho paura
che esplodano perfetto ok ti è morto
guardatelo
[Musica]
bene bene bene bene ok mi sono rialzato
c'è qualcosa da giu presumo di sì non ho
idea di che cosa ci possa essere ma noi
ci andiamo lo stesso anche perché non
vedo l'utilità di sto livello ma è
fantastico è fantastico anche se non
devi far nulla in particolare cos'è sta
roba è una tegola ho tirato una craniata
lo trasfigura infatti se anche alzato
bravo ammirazione almeno non ti sei
preso nei testicoli è già qualcosa
[Musica]
beh no niente anche l'altro spigolo per
favore oddio che mal di testa ci avrai
alla fine
vabbè tanto esplodi su delle bombe a
caso cadi dei ponti terremoti non credo
che un mal di testa possa cambiarti la
vita
se però riesce ad alzate in piedi mi fai
un favore niente niente
ok ci siamo cessa tegola che non ho
capito che cosa mi serve che penso sia
un residuo del delle esplosioni di prima
eva può dire che abbiamo vinto abbiamo
vinto anche perché sono l'unico
partecipante
mentre mentre continuativa le testate il
mio personaggio vedo di cambiare ma
perché è veramente stupendo un livello
chiamato pur non i dari che cosa possa
essere ma proviamo anche perché non ne
ho idea
siamo in due soltanto quindi ti farò il
culo e basta
non siamo in due tutto qua è una roba
dritta e basta
bello vai che vinco vai vai nell addio
primo privo hai toccato prima tutte
erano rompere per quanto stessi per
cadere primo invece lo sbalzo mi ha
fatto cadere per ultimo quindi ho vinto
io
però cosa è saltato tutto in aria senza
motivo perfetto devo riprovarci perché
devo provare a vedere se riesco a fare
un salto migliore più che altro vai ok
ok ok va giù ai giochi è perfetto primo
di nuovo su ca dove di questo lo vedi
questo
questo è il tuo premio perché ho vinto
io cosa devo fare ragazzo di quando
cadono insomma che cosa fare tipo cosa
fa così e la danza del robot a terra
[Musica]
a furia di fare la danza del ramo volti
il bianco sta finendo veramente male
però godetevi la scena perfetto a chi è
a parte la danza del robot e tutto il
resto vedo di passare all'ultimo livello
che
è quello che mi è rimasto nel cuore
diciamo ok so che ve lo ricorderete dal
primo episodio di su motori dreams
ma questo rimane il mio livello
preferito in assoluto perché veramente
ho riso come non fa cosa e ci riprova
stavolta verde vedi non farti incastrare
la testa nella tegola vai così ma è così
perfetto nord e nuova verde no verde no
il verde si perde un masochista ragazzi
si sia ammazza da solo si vuole male
non ha senso io cioè col culo all'area
adesso cosa sta facendo
vabbè comunque guarda te verde sepolto
vivo adesso mi ci butto anche sopra
dacci tua prossima volta non va in mezzo
è un masochista è sempre lui che si fa
del male però vabbè ok ragazza volta ci
vado io e mezzo perché non è che possa
impresa che sacrificarsi verde poverino
e vado vado io vado io si è sono morto
letteralmente
però va beh sono un unico in piedi tra
l'altro mi ha distrutto la schiena ma
sono ancora in piedi
si va per il blu ra il marrone ha fatto
un salto che non ho capito neanche come
ha fatto ma non importa
intanto li continuano a tirarsi pugni e
tutto il resto io non so cosa sto
facendo
tipo le flessioni guardate non ha senso
cosa sa cos'è ok ok basta
ho visto troppo lì proprio l'ultima
volta perché è veramente ne ho
abbastanza per oggi però è veramente
fantastico burden o burden ho dato io ok
ok che è successo guardate verde rete ok
ok ok perfetto perfetto perfetto il
verde ha preso possesso di uno scudo a
caso e non so perché questo livello il
verde deve sempre avere qualcosa in
mezzo al corpo nella testa come l'ultimo
l'ultimo episodio oppure sul braccio non
lo so ma qualcosa deve deve avere deve
farsi riconoscere ecco il marrone
innanzitutto sta facendo la cacca e non
so perché non si alza perfetto adesso si
è buttato lì dietro
io non vedo più i nostri personaggi ma
direi che per questo episodio posso
concludere qui anche perché ho fatto
talmente tanti tagli che per evitarlo ci
metterò 6 ore perché per evitare su
motori ragazzi ci metto ore ed ore in
marrone fatti osceni luogo pubblico ma
noi restiamo e va bene ok
che cosa è successo ma da quando esplode
st mappa l'ultima volta non era esplosa
ovviamente del marrone è rimasto
soltanto il braccio il marrone è sparito
ed è rimasto soltanto il braccio sotto
state gola ok ok lo vedete braccio no io
anche sono partito e va beh guardate
rimasto il braccio perché ti sei seduto
sul braccio del verde guarda non senso
ma perché il verde lì e si è staccato un
braccio
oddio ma che cosa poverino ha visto che
furia di fare il masochista ci rimani
secco però va bene raia condoglianze per
il braccio del verde pollice su per il
braccio del verde va beh
vedo di concludere qui l'episodio prima
che possa succedere qualcosa che possa
farmi cadere e arrotolare dalle risate
se vi è piaciuto il video come al solito
lasciato mi piace un commento qui sotto
anche la pagina facebook che trovate
sempre in descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi ho
dimenticato telecomando come al solito
se non siete ancora i siti iscrivetevi
ci vediamo al prossimo video col marrone
che esiste a partecipare e niente ci
vediamo prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]